What did you [music] do to this?
>> I mean, I've had this for 5 years.
>> I didn't ask how long you had it. I
asked what you did to it.
>> I [music] dropped it one time off of a
table like below my hip height. It
landed on the corner and it just got
[music] completely bent. All the other
damage is like Oh. OH [screaming]
YEAH. ONE OF THE screws is missing.
[laughter]
Uh, the screen is peeling here. It's
kind of like there's a crack. I put tape
over it, but there's a
>> That's an awful lot of words for, "Dad,
I need a new laptop." At least the
timing is good for this. He goes back to
school in a week. But with that said,
just because you're not back to school
yet, doesn't mean that you can't start
learning every other piece of technology
in his life. I've done the research.
I've made the purchase and pretty much
handed it to him. This time, you're on
your own. Oh, joy.
To be honest, it wasn't that hard to do
all the research. [music] I mean, I just
figured out what all the specs mean and
like what I want for school.
>> Okay. But are you sure you've actually
made a good decision?
>> I have a couple options for my top view
and then I'll I'll show those to you
[music] later.
>> Okay. So, I guess we'll get to find out
what that means to him. You started, of
course, by watching the LTT guide on how
to choose a laptop, right?
>> No, I didn't even know that was a thing.
>> Classic. But you know what everyone
knows is a thing is this segue to our
sponsor.
>> Oh Snap, the Sheamus Oh Snapperton
story. Learn the tale of how one simple
man with one [music] grand invention
helped a homestead get a grip and build
a life for themselves. Tune in tonight,
7:00 p.m. Pacific, 9:00 p.m. Central on
LT.
First things first,
why don't you show me the initial
research that you've done? [music]
>> Could we look at it on my phone instead?
>> Uh, you know, I'll get my laptop. Let me
have a look at what you got here.
>> Sorry, the notes might be a little bit
messy. I kind of just put everything in
random order.
>> Okay. Things I don't know. Gigahertz,
PCores, ECores, purpose of RAM, and is
that all stuff that you've figured out
already? Yeah, I researched about all of
these and then
>> Okay, so tell you what, without even
looking at the doc then, why don't you
try and summarize what exactly it is
that you're looking for?
>> I want a chip that is able to actually
run like 50 tabs at a time.
>> 50.
>> Well, yeah, if I have five subm's rookie
numbers, VRAMm drop.
>> OH, NO. BUT OKAY, go on.
>> Well, my old Chromebook would like crash
if I had 50 tabs open. So,
>> I want no lag with 50 tabs. Okay.
>> So, I probably need [music] like 16 GB
of RAM.
>> Okay.
>> And a chip with maybe 4 to 8 cores
[music] and
>> okay,
>> 4 to 5 GHz.
>> Okay.
>> For storage, I want at least 512 GB of
storage. 64 GB was fine on my old
Chromebook, but since it can't even
access Windows apps, it doesn't really
need much more storage,
>> right? So, that's a major difference.
This time he's going into high school.
So, all of a sudden, while the school
So, while the school allows him to use a
Chromebook, he actually doesn't have to
anymore. Maybe awkward question, though.
I walked down the stairs while you were
on your computer and I looked over your
shoulder and I saw apple.com. I was
thinking about it, but no, it's so
expensive. And the main benefit of all
your devices being connected to each
other, I don't even get that since I
don't have other Apple devices.
>> I mean, you got AirPods, but that's just
Bluetooth. I can connect that to
whatever.
>> That's fair enough. We actually had a
short conversation about it. He just
goes, "Why are these so expensive? Does
anyone actually buy these?" Yes. Yes,
they do.
>> It's like an addiction. Like once you
get into Apple, you can't get out. But
it's like you just have to get in first.
[music] So, I'm trying not to do that.
Okay. Okay. That's fair enough. The
MacBook Neo only has 8 gigs at nearly
$1,000. Yeah. The Neo used to be a
really good deal though when it first
came out, but now the price has gone up.
>> The price for everything went up. RAM is
so expensive. AI is like taking over. It
sounds like you actually want pretty
reasonable specs. I even see your weight
requirements here. You just want
something that's under 5 lbs. I mean,
[snorts] 5 lbs is really heavy. Do you
have any idea what a 5 lb laptop feels
like?
>> No.
>> You did all your research online, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Why don't we go look at some actual
laptops and experience them a little bit
before you make a final decision?
>> Okay.
>> Okay, let's do that. Where are we going?
Where are we going?
Where are you going?
He's new to filming. He doesn't doesn't
know how to walk out of the frame as a
transition.
[music]
>> Okay, but seriously, where are we going?
>> The original plan was for us to go
shopping, but what I realized is two
things. First, that since you did all of
your research online, the models that we
would see in store might not even be the
same ones that you saw in your research.
And number two is we sent our request to
Best Buy Langley to film in the store
too late, so we did not get permission.
So instead, [music] we're going to drop
by our inventory over at the lab. This
will give you a chance to, while it's
not necessarily the specific machine
you're looking at, really get a feel for
what different classes of machines feel
like.
I brought a shipping scale and a
backpack so you can have a look at
different weights of machines and like
put them on and see how they feel to
walk around with cuz you're going to be
carrying it basically all day.
>> Can't possibly be that heavy. 5 lb is
like
120th [music]
130th of my weight.
>> Okay, let's find a 5 lb machine then.
>> Oh my goodness. [laughter] See, this is
Is that really what you want? I didn't
think so. There's no way. This is This
has to be like 6 [music] lb.
>> 4.73 lb.
>> Okay.
>> A 5 lb laptop is a mondo like gaming
machine grade laptop, [music] which is
actually a pretty good question. Now,
obviously, I don't want it to distract
from your studies, but do you want
something that can run games at all?
>> I mean, kind of at least, but I do have
my PC at home, so I can just come home
and play games.
>> That is such a good answer. Love it.
Gold star. With all that said, I don't
know that you want to go completely to
the other end of the spectrum either.
>> Wow, that is tiny.
>> Yeah, that's one of the older LG Grahams
that really focused on being as light as
possible at the expense of,
you know, that it might come apart at
some point. And also, you don't get
really a very big battery. [music] I
need it to last the whole school day. If
it dies, that that sucks.
>> Another thing you haven't mentioned is
do you care what kinds of ports it has?
>> No, as long as it has a charging port.
>> Okay. Okay, doesn't matter.
>> Fair enough. Then is there anything that
you've seen then that has made you kind
of change your mind about the research
that you did so far?
>> I don't think so.
>> Okay. Want to show me what you settled
on then?
>> Yeah. Oh, was it too heavy for you?
>> What the No, the thing
>> No, you you like slammed the back of it
onto the shelf.
>> I mean, I don't know if that's what
happened.
>> It's like how you drop stuff off the
top.
>> 30%.
We got Oh god, a nice mouse. [snorts]
Fastest upgrade ever. How much does your
laptop cost?
>> Uh, don't worry about that. You're not
getting one like this. This is I think
about $4,000.
>> What? It has 128 gigs of like the
fastest RAM and 16 core processor.
Ludicrous onboard graphics. It's not the
kind of thing that I would actually buy.
[music] It's the kind of thing that our
ASUS rep just was like, "Hey, we really
want you to try this." And I was like,
"Okay, so you just get free stuff.
That's cool."
>> I mean, it's not really free. like I've
provided them a bunch of feedback on my
experience [music] with it. So that has
a value I think.
>> One pabyte.
>> Uh yeah. So our Google Drive storage
scales with how many people we have on
the account and we have like over 100
people. So
>> Oh, okay. I thought that was like on
here.
>> No. Heavens no. Okay. Show me what you
got.
>> There's three other things we haven't
talked about yet. Something with the
touchcreen because these trackpads, I
hate them so [music] much. it. Having to
click on these all day like hurts your
finger. They're not accurate.
>> Nobody tell them about MacBook
trackpads.
>> They're really good.
>> And then a large screen, too, cuz the
old 13.3 in [music] screen was just a
little bit too small.
>> Okay.
>> And then
120 Hz.
>> Okay.
>> After switching to my 120 Hz phone, 60
Hz just [music] doesn't feel the same
again.
>> Okay. Show me what you chose.
>> Go back to Lenovo after what happened to
your last one. That's bold. The last
laptop had a pretty low quality build.
It was like plastic and aluminum. These
ones are just aluminum.
>> Okay. All right. 15 in though.
>> Yeah. I want a big laptop so I can have
two tabs open at the same time.
>> All right. Idea Slim 5X.
Snapdragon. Interesting. Do you know
what that means? A brand. [music]
It's already fascinating watching a more
normie shopping experience. Snapdragon
uses a different instruction set
architecture, which basically means that
not all Windows apps will necessarily
run on that machine. They have good
performance. They get great battery
life, outstanding battery life, but you
might occasionally run up against a
piece of software that doesn't open.
>> What are some examples of that software?
>> Um, it's mostly not mainstream stuff.
It's mostly like, oh, I want to like run
this weird mod launcher for a game and
it might just not be compatible.
>> That's probably fine.
>> This one also doesn't have a gigantic
battery. 54.7 W hours is on the low
side, which is part of why this one is
at a more reasonable price. What do you
got next?
>> Here's the one that was on sale.
>> So, this is my You do not want a 16-in
laptop. Why not?
>> Okay, let's go get one.
>> I'll show you why.
That is a 16-in laptop. [music] It's
beautiful. Do most people not like big
laptops?
>> Tried to buy your mom a big laptop
recently and she literally took it back
to [music] the store. Every time I lend
you my laptop, you complain that the
screen is too small.
>> Well,
>> as long as it fits in my [music] LT
backpack,
>> it would be borderline. This is
[laughter] a This is a really big
laptop.
>> Do you have an LT backpack here?
>> What kind of a [music] question is that?
Something to note about this ThinkBook
though is that it has a more square
screen. So, it's actually going to be
even [music] larger, but not as like uh
side by side friendly. So, this is what
a 16-in laptop would look like in here.
You could stretch it around the corners.
>> Is this the commuter?
>> The same.
>> Okay.
>> Coming very soon in this colorway. By
the way, sign up for a notification.
ltstore.com.
>> Okay. It's not [music] even that much
bigger than yours.
>> All right.
>> Never mind. [laughter]
>> Oh, man. doesn't look bigger till you
realize it's diagonal and it's like
>> which is exactly why a 16-in screen is
so much larger than a 15.6. [music]
[snorts]
>> I mean, this would be nice having two
tabs.
>> Okay. All right.
>> And then these ones also have like the
number pad. So, when I'm in math, it's
way easier to do stuff. [music]
>> Okay. Not everybody likes the number pad
because what it means is that when
you're sitting dead on on your laptop,
you're kind of like this. [music] The
trackpad's centered relative to the
keyboard though.
>> Not all. This Lenovo does it and this
Vivo Book does it, but not all of them
do. So sometimes it can be a little
wonky. [music] Show me your third
choice.
>> So I thought this was a bad deal till it
went on sale and now I'm like, "Wow,
that's a good deal."
Dedicated GPU. Not a powerful one, but
absolutely enough to [music] play Rocket
League, for instance. Very gaming
oriented, but check the weight. [music]
And also, whenever you have a dedicated
GPU, you're going to get better
performance in games, but anytime you're
not running games, that GPU [music]
still has to be powered up a little bit.
So, you're going to give up a measurable
amount of battery life. I don't know
that there's any guarantee that this is
going to get through the day. And also,
that's in spite of it having a 90Wh hour
battery. So, that battery is physically
75 80% larger than that first machine
you showed me. And you got to carry all
that weight around, 2.2 2 kilos. Yeah,
that's a 5 lb thick boy machine.
>> 5 lb is way more than I thought it would
be.
>> I mean, you lift, don't you?
>> Well, yeah, but like a 5 lb weight is
lighter than a 5 lb laptop.
>> Huh.
>> It's like how cable lateral raises are
heavier than lateral raises. Like
>> Jim bro Logic.
>> Coming back to the Thinkbook 16 then, is
this your top candidate at the moment?
>> Yeah, because it has two cores more than
the idea pad and it's only like $40 more
expensive. Okay. Now, not all cores are
made equal. Did you learn about EC cores
and pores?
>> EC cores efficiency cores and pores
performance cores.
>> And there's even more to it than that.
So, depending on the generation of those
cores, they can be like way betterer or
way not nearly as good as the other
ones. [music]
>> So, eight cores could be worse than six
cores if the eight cores are like lower
generation.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, how do you how do you find the
generation? The generation number for
Intel is right here. So, these are last
gen. They're pretty okay, and the
battery life should be pretty solid.
This one, that's the newest generation,
but these are those Snapdragon ones that
have a bit less compatibility. [music]
So, either of them is a pretty solid
choice from a performance standpoint. Do
you think they're about the same?
>> It's hard for me to say for sure without
benchmarking them. I would say depending
on the application, this might be
faster, especially in like [music] light
single threaded tasks, but if you were
to say render out a video or something
like that, just having more cores is
probably going to benefit you more than
having faster ones. Is there anything
else you want to see? Oh, did did we
have one of these?
>> Surprise.
>> Oh, cool. So, we have a Thinkbook 16.
Okay, you get to experience it in person
then before you decide to buy it. So,
start with the weight.
It's not too bad, actually. I think
that's more what I was expecting for 5
lbs, [music] but you know, it's okay. I
think the trackpad's too offc center.
>> That's a bit of a Lenovoism.
>> Do you think the fans get really loud?
>> The fan shouldn't be too bad. It has
onboard graphics, so it's not really
like a powerful laptop or anything.
Won't sound like it's taken off.
>> The back lit keyboard is actually
something I appreciate more than I
thought I would. Like when you're in
[music] the dark, I don't know why you'd
be in the dark, but you can actually see
all the letters.
How come they always come with these
stickers?
Because the companies that make the
chips inside them really want people to
know about their chips.
>> So if the chip's bad, I'll know who to
blame it on.
>> Yeah. I don't think that's the way they
generally see it, but yes. Do you want
to see any other machines in our
inventory before you press order?
>> Yeah, I do. I want to see some of the
other like kinds of laptops.
>> Sure. Let's go have a look. This would
be a class of laptop that you haven't
seen yet.
>> Why does it have like an ammo box for a
[music] case?
>> Because it's loaded for bear, boy.
[laughter]
>> What?
>> No, this was not a meme. This was a real
product.
>> Who bought this?
>> Not many people.
>> It's not even portable. That's the whole
>> But it has a number pad.
>> I can barely even hold it.
>> And a full mechanical keyboard. This
one's interesting for your use case. It
was very expensive when it came out, but
I suspect it's worth a fair bit less
today. This is the Spectre Fold. It's so
light, too. Cool.
>> Well, you don't have the keyboard yet.
Okay,
so
there's your laptop.
>> Okay. Wow, the keyboard's very heavy.
>> But when it's time to get some work
done, you pop the kickstand
and that's your screen.
>> Do you think the six This is over or
under 16 in.
>> Over. The performance kind of sucks and
it thermal throttles and it's a little
bit loud, but it is a giant screen. 2K
USD.
>> That's very expensive.
>> That's very expensive, but not, you
know, totally totally outlandish.
>> I could get two of the Idea Pads for the
price of one of these.
>> That's true. But you can only use one
laptop at a time. So,
>> is it your money I'm spending or is it
my money I'm spending?
>> I mean, we're buying you a laptop for
school. Yeah.
>> So, it's your money.
>> Yeah. Also, I already have this, so
that's a factor.
>> How good do you think the performance
is?
>> Not very.
>> Never mind.
>> Like the worst.
>> Okay, no thanks.
>> Cool. Here's a 16-inch Galaxy Book.
>> Does this have good performance?
>> It's okay.
>> How much is [music] it? Oh, that
keyboard's nice.
>> It looks like a Galaxy Book 4 Edge would
be worth about a very similar budget
actually to what you were looking at.
So, this is an older last generation
Snapdragon chip, but those are already
pretty decent. 16 gigs of RAM, a
terabyte of storage, and 16inch screen.
>> What about battery life? Like, how many
hours do you think I could get?
>> You will get through the day. So, I
guess that's something that I didn't
really equip you with as part of your
shopping, but secondhand is always an
option and it can be a very attractive
one as long as you're not giving up
anything that really matters to you,
which in your case, it seems like mostly
comes down to battery life. Are you
ready to make a decision? Who will you
give your rose to?
>> I don't know. I kind of like this one.
Does it have a touchcreen?
>> Uh, probably. Yes. OLED touchscreen.
>> Is it 120 Hz?
>> Probably not. [music] No, it's 120 Hz
according to Gemini and according to
notebook check, which I believe before
Gemini.
>> Okay. Wow. This actually fits all the
requirements. Okay. I'm going to double
check the price cuz I feel like we may
have been looking at the wrong models.
No. No. They're actually like really
reasonably priced. Wow. These book four
edges might be a bit of a hack. Here it
is. Here's the 16-in AMOLED model for
about $1,000 Canadian. 16 gigs of RAM.
It has a little bit less storage than
this one, but this is clearly the same
machine.
>> I think this might be the one then.
[snorts]
>> All right, big moment.
Borderline,
but it still fits.
>> Do we have a decision then?
>> Yeah, I'm going to take this this
laptop.
>> All right, happy back to school. We
settled on Go figure. Samsung's one of
those companies that I do know
cognitively that they make laptops, but
I always forget about them. But this
ended up being a looks like a pretty
solid choice. And this is a pretty solid
segue.
Leave me hanging.
>> Oh, I'm supposed to say it to our
sponsor.
>> In the fall of 20019, early settlers
made their way west to begin on a
homesteading adventure. They tilled
their fields, grew their [music] grain,
and yet time and time again faced a
troublesome dilemma. While they worked,
[music] the folks of this small town
were distracted. or worse, dropped their
slippery phones [music]
as they played bus stop borders and
watched their favorite programs. As the
cold of winter crept in, Sheamus O
Snapton knew the homes wouldn't finish
on time when his friends kept dropping
the phones and he thought, "Damn, their
phone accessories kind of suck." So for
his people, he made something that
didn't suck. And it stuck. Magnetic,
ultra thin, offering a handle and a way
for them to prop up their devices. The O
snap grip stand. Suddenly, the
homesteaders were able to work while
watching YouTube, doom scrolling, or
playing Cabbage Crush Saga. The premium
and minimal build had the workers
impressed, free to fidget, and worked
with all of their devices. And now you
too can have a piece of the O Snap
Legacy with you in your pocket. 25% off
sitewide with the link down below. If
you guys enjoyed this video and you like
these kind of shopping vibes videos,
maybe check out the time that Elijah and
I went shopping for a printer.
It's way more exciting than it sounds.